- [Instructor] The goal of this video
is to find the solution set
for the following equation.
So all of the X values, and we're dealing
with radians, that will
satisfy this equation.
So I encourage you, like
always, pause this video
and see if you can work
through this on your own
before we worked through it together.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
Now your intuition, which
would be correct, might be,
let's see if we can isolate the sin
of X over four algebraically.
And the first step I
would do is subtract 11
from both sides.
And if you do that, you
would get eight sin of X
over four is equal to three,
just subtracted 11, both sides.
Now to isolate the sin, I would
divide both sides by eight
and I would get sin of X
over four is equal to 3/8.
Now, before I go further,
let's think about
whether this is the most
general solution here
or whether we're going to find
all of the solution set here.
Well, we have to remind ourselves,
let me actually draw a little
bit of a unit circle here.
So that's my X axis.
That's my Y axis.
Then a circle.
And if we have some angle
theta right over here.
So that's theta, we know that
the sin of theta is equal
to the Y coordinate
of where this radius
intersects the unit circle.
And we also know
that if we add an arbitrary
number of two pies here
or if we subtract an
arbitrary number of two pis,
we go all the way around the unit circle,
back to where we began
and so the sin of theta would be the same.
So we know that sin of theta
plus any integer multiple
of two pi, that's going to
be equal to the sin of theta.
And so we can generalize
this a little bit.
We can instead of just
saying, sin of X over four
is equal to 3/8, we could
write that sin of X over four
plus any integer multiple of
two pi is going to be equal
to 3/8 where N is any integer.
It could even be a negative
one, a negative two
or of course it could be
zero, one, two, three,
so on and so forth.
So is this, if we solve now for X,
is this going to give us the
most general solution set?
Well, we can also remind ourselves
that if I have theta here
and sin if theta gets there.
There's one other point on the unit circle
where I get the same sin.
It would be right over here.
The Y coordinate would be the same.
And one way to think about it is
if we start at pi radians,
which would be right over there
and we were to subtract theta,
we're going to get the same thing.
So this angle right over here,
you could view as pi minus theta.
And you could keep trying
it out for any theta,
even the theta that put
you in the second quadrant,
third quadrant or fourth quadrant,
if you do pi minus theta,
sin of pi minus theta,
you're going to get the same sin value.
So we also know that sin of pi minus theta
is equal to sin of theta.
And so let me write another
expression over here.
So it's not just sin of X over four
is equal to 3/8.
We could also write that
sin of pi minus X over four,
'cause X over four is the theta here.
Sin of pi minus X over
four is equal to 3/8.
And of course we can also
use the other principle
that we can add 2 pi or
subtract two pi from this,
an arbitrary number of times
and the sin of that will
still be equal to 3/8.
So I could write it like this.
Sin of pi minus X over four
plus an integer multiple
of two pi, that is going
to be equal to 3/8.
And if I solve both of these,
the combination of them, the union of them
would give me the broadest solution set.
So let's do that.
So over here, let me take the
inverse sin of both sides.
I get X over four plus two pi N is equal
to the inverse sign of 3/8.
Now I could subtract two
pi N from both sides.
I get X over four is equal
to the inverse sin of 3/8, minus two pi N.
And if you think about it,
because N can be any integer,
this sin here in front of the two,
this negative really doesn't matter.
It could even be a positive.
And now let's multiply both sides by four.
We get X is equal to four
times the inverse sin
of 3/8 minus eight pi N.
And then if I work on this
blue part right over here,
same idea, take the
inverse side of both sides.
We get pi minus X over
four plus two pi N is equal
to the inverse sin of 3/8.
And then let's see, I can
subtract pi from both sides
and subtract two pi N from both sides.
And so I get negative X over four is equal
to the inverse sin of 3/8
minus pi minus two pi N.
And I multiply both
sides by negative four.
I get X is equal to negative
four times the inverse sin
of 3/8 plus four pi plus eight pi N.
And as I mentioned, the
union of both of these
give us the entire solution set
to our original equation here.